the thing about this like frail asian
kid wearing a beanie walking around you
look like a [ __ ] cancer patient
so i was like i'm tired of this i want
to change my style right
there right so i went for the skinhead
look i looked like a complete
i look like i just came out of prison
man
hello and welcome to another episode of
the trash taste
podcast i am your host for today gant
that is a real name i can assure you and
i'm joined today
with my co-host connor and joey the ones
with the real names
the the actual real name the actual real
name the whitest man on earth
so by the time this comes out this would
have been very old by now but we haven't
really got a chance to have
had a real debrief on our cycling
special oh yeah
um because we we filmed an outro and
that turned out to be 26 minutes or
something like that and we were just
like
yeah originally and people we were like
people don't want to hear us talk about
a special thing by the way
if you haven't watched the cycling
special you should go and do that before
we we're going to talk he's talking
about that video so if you want to watch
that link down below or
on screen now but um i think the biggest
thing i mean obviously the reaction for
that has been absolutely
incredible but what i found funny was
how seriously people took when it came
to
discussing who won and who lost and who
cheated
in that cycling special there was i've
never seen
like our subreddit turn into like just
the most like
no you don't it was a [ __ ]
free-for-all for a good
for a good period of time there it was
it was like it was like a [ __ ] like
team guard
and joey versus team connor battle is
this how the twilight fandom were in
their prime
yeah i mean i get it you know they they
they're invested they're investing which
is good
yeah yeah but i mean okay i think i i'm
very like i'm very fake salty like i'm
always like
fake i think we are all fake salty and
fake but like in real life as well i'll
get like i'll start like getting like
i'll sound like loud i'm like yo this is
[ __ ] up and then i'll be like well you
you really can't like no no not really
i just like getting annoyed about things
in a way that isn't like that's very
twitter
yeah yeah yeah british very british it's
like this is i can't believe this
oh my god really like i don't know [ __ ]
i mean like you know
the chili i was like at the moment i'm
sure when i found out you cheated i was
like
[ __ ] and then i probably just
thought like all right yeah yeah yeah
but then obviously
because there's also clips of like me
talking about on my live stream but
obviously like i play up the saltiness
because i have you know it's good
showmanship you know
but it's unfortunate that like a large
majority of the internet doesn't
understand sarcasm there was
so i there was a there was like enough
subreddit people discussing
yeah who cheated who really won the real
world who done it
there was this one comment i can't
remember where it was called but they
were like it was like big man connor
cahoon
thinks he's a real winner real chad huh
calling his friends
cheetahs when he cheated he was getting
so angry about it and i was like what
the [ __ ]
it was just so funny seeing how like the
fact that
there were so many people who are
infinitely more saltier than we are like
we didn't give a [ __ ] it's like to us
it's you know we make the video we film
it yeah yeah if someone cheats you know
it's
and it makes for good content it makes
for good content yeah yeah i mean
originally i remember going on a cycling
special i i think i i
this this got cut out the uh video but i
remember telling connor
yeah i'm gonna do the whole thing
because you know
i'll feel good if i do the whole thing
yeah and so the fourth challenge
happened
and then joey suggested the cheating and
i just thought to myself
that'll make for a really funny segment
if we do actually that's exactly what it
was it's like yeah
you know saying that oh i wanted to take
a [ __ ] free car ride like you know
i'd be lying if i say i didn't want that
but ultimately i was like no no let's do
this because it'll make for great
content and it did it's not it's not
about the race it was about
friendship it was it wasn't about it it
was about the friends we lost along the
way
which is apparently each other very true
no because like i i feel like you know
it's there's there's a difference
between
obviously none of their scripted which
you know it's it we don't script what
happens on the specials but we we are
still
you know we we are we do still have that
my that voice in the back of our head
that says this is going to be content
people are going to watch this for
entertainment
because let's be real like you know
there was a part of me that was like
you know i'm sure there will be some
level of entertainment factor if
hypothetically all three of us with no
accidents whatsoever
completed everything from start to
finish but you know it's the little bits
of
unexpected drama that makes for an
interesting drama it's the banter i i
feel like that's what makes for the
interesting video
i feel like part of this discussion it's
it's like we
we laugh at it because we know we didn't
take it seriously but i'm glad people
are that invested in our content to
really go
balls deep to really like break down the
levels of cheating
yeah and like okay i had like i i swear
some people could make a spreadsheet
of like every little thing that like
there's like thesis papers
like the dream cheating thing yeah
who cheated technically there's a one in
seven trillion chance that
god's chain would break at that very
moment
there was one comment there's like why
didn't gon just put the chain back on i
did think that i was like with the god
why didn't god put the chain back
actually
this wasn't uh there's a lot of my you
know trying to fix the chain did get cut
out but it was like
completely lodged in there so yeah yeah
like uh the three the reason you were
waiting so long for us was because i was
like trying to unlodge this [ __ ]
chain
and then like i got it back on and then
it came off again immediately and i
was trying to figure out what the [ __ ]
was wrong with my bike so i had this
like half an hour to 45 minutes
where i realized that i had gone the
entire cycle
without uh without first gear so so
the reason the reason the chain came off
was because when i went went to
um the highest it just slipped off um
yeah these bikes were very cheap and
like i i realized why i was suffering
so much now on the [ __ ] hills was
because
i i was in second gear the entire way um
i also love though how like there was so
many comments even on the video being
like
oh man their seats are too low their
bikes are too small it's like
look that was the biggest bikes they had
those were the biggest bikes and i think
i did adjust my seats to be the highest
so the highest
um because these people are designed for
japanese people by far
because these we didn't buy the bikes
there were the rental bikes from the
lake because we had a place to
fly to the other side of the country
yeah so we couldn't bring these bikes
we're definitely not suited for six foot
foreigners that's for sure
speak for yourself five foot gang over
here
even but even for your size it was
smaller that was just
maybe okay for me but like i'm really
pushing it like yeah yeah yeah yeah
because i remember i put my seat all the
way to the top i was like oh no this is
the highest it goes i'm gonna [ __ ]
okay we're pretty [ __ ] dumb right
yeah we're not we're not that dumb
like i saw comments that were also like
they did they even use any gears i'm
like bro
you'd know i can't you wouldn't know if
we didn't change gear because god would
not be moving up anything
else i think god could pedal at six gear
up a hill i was already suffering enough
on second gear let alone [ __ ]
some people pretend like it was the
first time we ever saw a bicycle with
gears
like that day it's like what what are
these things let's just leave it alone
i didn't realize until i saw the footage
actually how much of a
how much of a clown i looked with like
this [ __ ] bike
with my massive legs just like just like
pedaling along you're basically on like
one of those like you know the kid bikes
like young and like sitting there the
feet are going
oh man that dude squats every time i'm
glad people enjoyed it but man
just it's not that serious guys it was
just it was just a little bit of i mean
there was a lot of there was a lot of
like fluff that got cut out shout out to
mudan
for editing that and going through jesus
how much footage
like 100 hours between us because it was
like we had
the six gopros it was like one terabyte
of footage
we had six gopros for so two gopros
between each of us and then also the
handycams and whatever and the gopro in
the camera uh the gopro and the car as
well which is
that's why it took so long we filmed
that in october that's why
the production took so long for our next
special we
probably won't like scale up until we
have like a super super big idea maybe
try something a bit smaller you know
yeah i feel like at this rate it's just
gonna get like bigger
it's going to turn into like a mr beast
yeah yeah if we don't scale back a
little bit i mean because we're the ones
mainly arranging this as well so we have
to come up with all the equipment we
need
to figure everything out and so like
it's quite it's quite a lot to do it for
us like i i kind of realized this when
uh we were doing the thing and then
connor's
tire popped and every comment was just
like wow
i can't believe they didn't plan for
like a spare tire or something like that
and
yeah in hindsight it sounds [ __ ]
stupid doesn't it
but you have to understand that most of
our planning went into
how the [ __ ] are we going to power six
gopros yeah yeah
on our bicycles when we have one car and
none of us near each other yeah
so we we were trying to figure out the
logistics of trying to get this filmed
and that's where the last thing we were
expecting was a pop-tart yeah yeah
these bikes were like extra heavy
because we had like duct tape the [ __ ]
out of stuff to it like there was like
portable batteries
strapped to these like a break just to
like keep the gopro and also gopros are
such
fickle things they're amazing when they
work but the moment like there's any
heat
they just stop working yeah because we
realized this during the drifting
special because
people look at this content and think
they they don't see the [ __ ]
effort and logistics that goes into this
because i didn't think about this until
i had to go out and film it they just
think oh just buy some cameras and
attach it yeah so with the with the
drifting special a lot of connor's
footage just got lost yeah so like it's
a shame because like
the when i was doing like the sick
doughnuts like all of that footage was
lost because the gopro just
overheated in like five minutes 100
degrees yeah
yeah it's an oven in that thing and mine
turned off luckily your guys has worked
mine kept dying in the second half yeah
yeah it just sucked because like all you
get to see is an outside shot it doesn't
even look like i'm in the car doing the
[ __ ] thing and you missed all like me
getting [ __ ] hyped screaming
spoiler it was a stunt dog yeah exactly
like it looks like it could look like a
stunt dog yeah it's so sad i'm like
that's my trip
like i recently watched this horror
movie with sydney i don't remember the
name it's a korean horror movie right
but
the premise of this horror movie is that
there's this company who basically does
live stream content
right and so this company hires a bunch
of
people from the public to live stream
going into this like
haunted haunted asylum and you know live
streaming their experiences there
um and so i was watching this movie and
they
they had this like jank set up with some
gopros that are apparently like live
streaming to this base camp that was
like
like a literal camp that they had set up
outside this mental asylum right yeah
and when i was watching this i couldn't
get invested in the movie because i felt
like that guy doing like
youtuber reacts to youtuber movies right
and all i could see in the back of my
head was
they these gopros don't even have any
spare cameras [ __ ] lie there they
were like live streaming for five hours
or something like that two out of ten
not really yeah yeah there's no way that
would work also
how are they getting signal in this
mental asylum there's no way the stream
would be this clean
while they were streaming places inside
backpacks exactly
they didn't even have the [ __ ] 5g
twitch backpacks like this is
fake movie two out of ten
oh my god i mean i'd like to do
something like that but like just you
know
the [ __ ] effort it would take to just
try and organize the technicalities
behind that just sounds like a nightmare
in and of itself
yeah i mean to me twitch uh like irl
streamers are just built different i
don't know
like i don't know i think you have to be
an another level of like masochist
yeah i think i i to me it seems like why
would you want to be embarrassed in
public
yeah yeah like constantly yeah i don't
mind doing it for a video every now and
then yeah but like
having it constantly on because at least
in a video
when you're out there filming when
you're out and about there filming at
least you can like edit it so it's the
most
interesting things that happened on the
day but if it's an irl stream
you see everything and i'm just and it's
just especially
when you're not even even in the safety
of your own home either you're out there
in public people can see you people can
judge you
and to me that's just a level of like
that's that's the dystopian future that
i i don't want in my life
i don't know yeah i've gone wrong yeah i
was saying like not to mention like
in japan especially where people are
already [ __ ]
way too wary about filming in public
right
yeah i i don't know how you can just
like rock up to an izakaya full of
people and just be like yeah i'm just
gonna put this camera here and just
start talking
yeah i i i i don't know i don't i
couldn't do that either i don't know i
haven't tried it but like
i i don't know how it i would get over
that mental barrier
of just going going to around
restaurants like having the phone in
front of me and just talking to the
phone now i'm too british i can't do
that
the thought of going into just a place
and doing that is like what like just
like on the street as well like
i don't get how like like j vloggers for
instance can like just be walking on the
streets by themselves
just have a camera like this and being
late all right guys so we're going to go
to blah blah blah and just
have people staring at you i've done
that it looks like a [ __ ]
hostage video i'm like [ __ ] talking
down to the camera like yeah like i i i
wouldn't go like
some people just like yeah hello hello
the giant selfie stick outwards this is
everyone in ikebukuro right now
check it out like i don't know i mean to
me it's like you know and i watch some
of these irl streams except i'm quite
interested in it myself and i think yeah
like oh maybe i could do it sometime but
then
you know when i watch it i'm like okay
cool they did like one cool thing in the
day
and the rest of it like a lot of the
time they were just being like sitting
there asking their chat like what do you
guys want to do
you just want to do what should we do
guys and it's like all right and then
anybody get what the appeal was because
most of the time
real life's pretty [ __ ] boring you're
just like traveling or waiting
yeah exactly i think though in this day
and age i feel it's a type of content
that is like really small
yeah maybe right now i can understand
that but before that i'm like why would
you want to watch someone just kind of
like wait
and sit around all day and maybe do
something interesting for one hour
because
it's like you're really there i i get it
in covert times isn't this some kind of
like black mirror-esque [ __ ] that we're
getting on though like
i just want i don't want to have a day
myself i'm gonna watch someone else have
a day
and i'm going to give them money it's
literally that [ __ ]
image of you know that kid sitting in
front of like the the poster and being
like
every podcast be like that just keeps
getting posted on our subreddit
yeah that's really what that is cause
like for me like i i feel awkward
if i have a hands-free set and i'm just
in public
and i'm on the phone like sometimes i
have hands-free set and i have the phone
up to my face
to look like i'm talking on the phone
yeah as opposed to exactly supposed to
talking to myself i don't know yeah
because the other day uh
i had to go buy like some uh some like
eyelashes for archie
so i went to like the local was it this
one yeah no yeah the local pharmacy and
i was like
[ __ ] i don't know which one she wants so
so i tried to like
you know take some pictures and send up
being like yeah pick out which one it is
and she just [ __ ] calls me and it's
like
just show me so i had to like flip the
camera and i'm just i'm just doing this
while talking on a hands-free set and
these old women are looking at me like
what the [ __ ] is this guy doing
like that they probably understand
filming eyelashes
and being like which one i don't know
why i find like
only irl content is where it feels a
little black mirrory to me a little
weird i don't know why like
no other type of content makes me feel
in that weird kind of
this is like no other content makes you
feel like this is too far
like irl just some something about it
sometimes i'm watching it i'm like
well because like i feel that like if
you stream in like say a studio like
this right
there's like a performative side to it
it's almost like a stage or like a setup
like like there is literal sets that we
perform in like yes yeah
but sitting down for like three hours at
an izakaya while like having a casual
beer it's a little too realistic
as well like i saw a lot of them like a
lot of them get like drunk a lot of the
time and that's like the audience
loves that oh yeah they love it when
they get drunk because they're like oh
they could [ __ ] up they could say
stuff like so the audience constantly
eggs them into drinking yeah people are
like waiting for the next like stream
and i'm like i'm like [ __ ] is that
that's a horrible relationship to have
your viewers where they just want to see
you [ __ ]
[ __ ] everything that's probably yeah i
mean i i feel like even though
even though you're it's an irl stream
you know when we're streaming we do have
this performative side to us that we
just talked about um that we feel like
we want to be
we want something interesting to happen
or we at least want an interesting
conversation to happen
so i feel like it's a very i
i don't know like unhealthy kind of like
relationship to have with your viewers
at that point because your your best
interest
is for something to happen so you are in
this performative side and i've talked
to a few irl streamers who
have done things on their streams which
they probably wouldn't have done if
you know nobody is watching right yeah
you definitely get that like fake
confidence yeah yeah stream watching you
i mean isn't that where like the whole
generalization of like
you know fan bases of ireland streamers
being like
they're pretty [ __ ] toxic yeah like i
i know a couple of viral streams in
japan as well and you know they're all
lovely people
yeah you know off stream yeah but i
think it's because of the fact that they
have this really
toxic and you know quite aggressive type
of audience that loves to egg them on to
make them do
stupid [ __ ] or you know fail in some way
that they kind of get
dragged into that yeah you know hate to
say it
a lot of them on stream turn into a bit
of an [ __ ] but that's also because
you know you have thousands sometimes
tens of thousands of people being like
yo
do this thing that makes you look like
an [ __ ] for our entertainment yeah
it's kind of unfortunate because it's
like a you know if you're being an
[ __ ]
you know but your audience is enjoying
it and the egging you on you could you
can almost get lost in the fact that
no i don't think i'm being an [ __ ] i
think i'm being entertaining right right
right i think so but then you know you
see them when you talk to them one on
one you realize
oh they're actually quite normal nothing
like they are nothing like this they're
really nice most of the time i don't
know
maybe i'm over generalizing i don't know
i haven't met many but the ones i have
met are very different to how they act
on stream
yeah yeah i mean yeah i only really know
like a few who are like exactly the same
but
that's i feel it's a rare breed yeah
yeah but i i feel i i completely agree
with you with like irl stream content
being
the black mirror kind of content as
opposed to any other
stream kind of content in my opinion and
i'm not sure why maybe it's because
it's you it literally is like kind of
like a slice of life where it's
it feels a bit too intimate i feel
especially when it's those irl streams
where it's like it's not the camera
pointing at the person but it's like
shot in pov
yeah yeah like that [ __ ] especially it's
like whoa
it's just weird it's just it just makes
you think like where's it gonna go from
here like what's the next step because
it's gonna be a next step and like i'm
just
it's only going to one-up itself yeah
which is why i'm like i wonder where
it's going to go
like it's just it's really interesting
streaming my wife's pregnancy
kind of scary honestly i i i i could see
that happening
screaming my child's birth
streaming my child's conception dad
reacts to child birth well
it's like those [ __ ] oh there it is
there are those families on youtube that
have like more kids because
more kids is more clickbait pregnancy
oh my god i just got reminded of that
video you found the other day connor
about the uh
the uh what's up what's in your bum
challenge right what's up
what was it yeah because i mean i follow
like justin wang on twitter i don't know
if you follow justin wang
yeah yeah this man [ __ ] he loves
retweeting the most poor [ __ ]
this man [ __ ] retweets and posts the
cursed [ __ ] and i and i thought this has
got to be a troll
yeah but there's literally a series on
youtube of people being like is that
is that a dildo or a dick in my house on
youtube
no joke this isn't a joke i know it's
disgusting
and like i watched it because i was like
i thought it was me yeah i thought this
was like there was a meme
there's no way this was like the can
goku beat aids me yeah
we thought we thought was just a
photoshop picture and then you go in and
you have a look and they're like
literally
he's [ __ ] doing it and i'm like this
is on youtube
what the [ __ ] what is this
and then i just like oh yeah i think
that's your dick
and it's like what is happening
it's just like that moment of disbelief
where you just you can't quite believe
that this is this kind of content has
just
we've gotten to the point where we can
post something like this on youtube and
it's just it's not even a meme anymore
we went to [ __ ] like equals three to
this
[ __ ] what the [ __ ] happened what
happened who came up with the genre it's
a genre
more than one people is doing an actual
genre more than one person has done this
challenge it's like a dead ass like
youtube challenge like pass it on
tag the next creator who was gonna do a
new what's in my bum challenge
and before someone's like oh dude cause
it's like because it was like oh
people are gonna be like bro just
because you're saying cause it's like
dudes dude no if it was [ __ ] women
and guys doing it yeah
it's [ __ ] weird why is it on youtube
i think
i think what killed me was just how
straight they were
that they were playing it yeah there
wasn't any irony no
there wasn't there was zero irony there
was zero like
sarcasm and what they were doing they
were just like oh i
i think it's your dick but i don't like
i i can't trust my butt anymore yeah
please don't watch this it is literally
what it is it's the most cursed one of
the most personal videos
we went from like you know reaching into
a box to see what it is to just like
let's replace the boss with the anus
remember when fine bros or tv shows like
is it jelly or a spider
is it a dick is it a dildo or my dick
i'll never tell i can't i can't wait for
the next step which is like
which operation are we performing with
you is it a vasectomy
or a colonoscopy you tell me and it's
like oh okay
i think i'm being like my penis is being
surgically removed what is happening
the [ __ ] how how can youtube crack down
on dumb [ __ ] and then just leave this
[ __ ] up this is insane
i i couldn't believe it is it a mouth i
would own a hole i wore
a vagina sponsored by tango
a tango or is it my mouth i'll never
tell
i feel like there is a clear line in
which would should be
across honestly like when uh so yeah for
those of you who don't know
joey did a video where we review tango
products
great video check great video great
video um i found it funny because
joey didn't really tell me what we were
doing until the day of filming so
in the back of my mind i was just like
is joey just gonna make me like go
behind a curtain and just like try this
[ __ ] out like well like what am i doing
today
like how [ __ ] are we going to test
it out yeah
because joey was just like yo you want
to go test out some tengas and i'm just
like
yeah sure in what capacity
are we testing them out joey just boys
saying yeah just just another night with
the bros you know
creating a cold one with the boys
that was a great we yeah
yeah i just can't i can't believe that
video got made like that had to be like
filmed edited at no point in the process
people think is this too much no
the thing it wasn't just a one part
series it was multiple it's a multiple
part series
and it obviously did really well because
everyone just can't obviously did really
well because who's not going to [ __ ]
click on that when you see that it's
actually
because it's so absurd you're going to
be like what is this this can't be real
oh my god it's real don't watch it
please please please do not
exist do not watch this i've never felt
dirty just looking up at youtube
typing something into my youtube search
history you know i didn't watch a little
bit of it i don't know i did two
i did soon it was [ __ ] hilarious like
i i just found it really really funny
be great on pornhub yeah yeah great
funny jokes funny fun
pornhub fantastic meme fan [ __ ]
tastic mean on youtube you're just like
how are they getting away with how it's
still up it's beyond me what
so what is okay moving out of this like
what is
what is some of the most cursed [ __ ] you
have seen on youtube
i'm i'm actually curious now because i i
know it's probably honestly the most
cursed thing i've seen
it's probably it's pretty cursed it's
pretty [ __ ] up there i mean that that
is that is definitely up there but
if we're talking like classic like
cursed content like uh
you guys never watched uh no you ever
watched like pizza time
no i've seen that one no what's that
it's this video
from like i don't even know when it's
made sounds familiar but it's
basically these like a bunch of dudes
like uh you watch
teenage mutant ninja turtles right yeah
you know how they're like obsessed with
pizza
yeah so it's basically like a a [ __ ]
post on that but it's basically this
like
explaining it is so weird but it's
basically just like a bunch of dudes
dressed up in ninja turtle cosplay
and then they like whip out their like
fake dicks and like
jack off onto this like pizza what
have you not seen it no this is this is
on youtube
it's on youtube wait i i got
no the video is silent that's the that's
the most cursed thing about it yeah
the entire video is silent and it's
easily the most i don't even remember
your own soundtrack yeah i don't even
remember where i [ __ ] saw it but like
it was one of those like you know
[ __ ] cursed content that made his
rounds on you know it's like [ __ ] yeah
yeah spinning that kind of [ __ ] right
but it was on youtube instead of her own
dedicated website i feel like you don't
really have
intentions don't look it up yeah yeah
please don't literally see it
often is the way it used to be i don't
know it used to be like kind of a like
bonding experience yeah you'd watch
cursed content
but now it doesn't feel that much now
just things like i feel like everyone
thinks you're a [ __ ] weirdo
if you watch that [ __ ] i mean it's kind
of true though
it doesn't matter if you do it on your
own or do it as a group it's still weird
yeah
i mean it's i mean i remember when
youtube went through the point where
pretty much you can you can say anything
was a prank and just like
and just get away with it like just just
physically assault someone and call it a
prank
the [ __ ] was his name uh uh what's this
scent no sam pepper
oh god you remember that guy uh what was
it he used to be an iron streamer as
well yeah yeah
yeah i did the prank oh yeah well he uh
killed his best friend yeah
wait what do you remember that have you
seen that one so he actually did a prank
where he would kidnap one of us two of
his friends
right and then he would pretend to kill
one of them in front of the other friend
and it was a prank it was like just like
are you serious this is a thing
yeah this is a huge deal huge yeah
people people were honest ass about it
i'm rightly so yeah that sounds it's
pretty [ __ ] up
and it's like and it's like in the video
like you just see this like
dude like in a [ __ ] like bag over his
head just like getting fake shot
right what and the guy this is a black
mirror episode way there's a guy and the
other friend is like strapped to the
championship
[ __ ] breaking down crying and he's
like that's just the prank bro
you just thought his best friend got
murdered so of course naturally your
natural response is to freak the [ __ ]
out yeah
just mentally scared my best friend for
life haha just the prank bro honestly
it was [ __ ] well it reminds me of that
um like the recent news that broke where
someone actually
got shot or got murdered in america or
something because
they were filming like a prank video
right oh that's right and they were like
approached
i think they were like fake mugging
people yeah really yeah yeah
there was this guy i can't remember the
exact details of the story but there was
this kid or something
who like was just pretending to mug
people or like yeah are you pretend
amongst them
i guess i just go up to another knife
play the youtube raw teeth
i'm taking your money the ukulele
unfortunately more than one body and now
when it comes to youtube pranks gone
wrong or whatever
yeah wait wait so what happened to the
what getting like
just to me it seems so you're literally
in america everyone has a gun
yeah i mean it's not even just in
america in any [ __ ] country what what
can you expect
you just pull a [ __ ] knife out i'm
just gonna beat the [ __ ] out i feel like
well it's off
this episode is sponsored by rituals we
deserve to know what we're putting in
our bodies
and why you're right rituals clean
vegan-friendly multivitamin is
formulated with high quality nutrients
in bioavailable forms your body can
actually use damn
boys do you know what you won't find
what sugars
yeah gmos major allergens synthetic
fillers
and artificial colorants god that is
insane plus gone plus the fresh taste
and delayed release capsule design
make taking your vitamins easy get out
of here
i've been waiting for it i want
everything to be easy life ritual
guys ritual is designed with your life
stage in mind
now available for women men and teens
ritual multivitamins are scientifically
developed to help support different life
stages don't forget ritual is also made
traceable you'll always know what
nutrients you're taking and where they
come from
thanks to rituals one of a kind visual
supply chain
so get your key nutrients today without
the bs ritual is offering you
our listeners 10 off during the first
three months so visit ritual.com
trash taste to start your ritual today
damn i see what they did there
i i i see what they did i see what they
did thank you for sponsoring the episode
back to the show
speaking of arseholes online and people
are acting like arseholes online yeah
i'm scared yeah going back to the uh
cycling special yeah so we've i mean
we've
it's funny how we've talked about
like online privacy so so much on this
podcast
yeah we've talked about it a lot and
sometimes i feel like we're you know
beating a dead horse because we're just
like yeah you know we we have a lot of
crazy stories
yeah um so it kind of surprises me when
there are still some people
out there despite how many times we've
talked about it
we'll do some uh not pretty pretty not
cool stuff yeah i mean uh
so if if you haven't been following my
twitter so yeah someone
someone tried to leak some monk photos
that
i had which were private on my mum's
facebook and yeah
uh i mean i i said this i said this on
my twitter longer but you know i
i purposely didn't release it because
you know it's i'm fine people
knowing that i was a monk and meaning
that aspect just you know
meaning the knowledge or whatever but i
was just like i i kept
that part private because you know there
are like quite intimate photos it's like
a
religious ceremony so i didn't i didn't
want that part of my life there i mean
because when you initially told the
story i remember after it you were like
yeah boys i don't want to show a photo
i'm pretty sure he said it on the clip
did you like i'm pretty sure on the clip
we were like i think one of us said like
oh we'll put the pictures and then god
was like no i don't want to put the
pictures oh yeah
i think i might have said that it's been
a while it's been a while
i remember being like you didn't want to
share the pictures we were like yeah i'm
just sure whatever i understand what
happened
yeah and you know it's become a meme i'm
completely fine with you know being the
monk has become a meme
but uh yeah someone someone literally
stalked my mum's facebook
um which you know it's there's there's
there's a difference between you know if
i [ __ ] up and you know i
there's some part of my private life
that you know i forgot to private you
know
it's still an [ __ ] move but you know
as a public figure you can expect that
people are going to try and dig into
your past everything like that just
in and of itself yeah yeah i mean it's
you know we can talk about that
[ __ ] that you know we kind of had to
expect that but you kind of do have to
expect that but
it just felt dirty that someone tried to
stalk my family especially like my close
family yeah
that's actually [ __ ] yeah it's pretty
funny and like these are really old
pictures as well so they would have had
to go back
years and years worth of like my mom's
pictures that she had so creepy to think
someone's just scrolling
i don't know and and like all this all
this for a meme
it's like it's like that thanos mean
like all this for like a single meme
yeah
as well the person knew that they were
being scummy as well yeah they even like
self-admitted that they were like
yeah i know this is scummy lol it's like
nah
because i i feel like you know we i mean
we literally talked about this last week
where you know the
the barrier of privacy between reality
and what's entertainment is like slowly
slowly
drifting apart and slowly being erased
and
i don't know it feels weird finally
experiencing that for myself
and being in the crossfire yeah it sucks
i mean i i'd like to tell my parents i
was like you know
because luckily my parents you know
they're mega boomers
so they they think that facebook is the
play can always has people yeah so they
never signed up to it
yeah um but i still have to tell them
like listen if anyone asks you questions
about me
or like anything private about me and
tries to get anything just tell them
like okay
don't answer it just tell them to ask me
like if if
even if it's like you know like someone
claiming to be like a government agency
which like i think somebody
i remember who called them up and asked
somehow got my parents number or
something and i'm like trying to ask
them questions about me and i was like
don't don't answer anything
just you know if the police want me the
police will find me right i mean like
yeah anyone who claims to be anything
don't [ __ ] tell them anything
it's sad that you have to do that right
yeah like the thought i think it's just
really sad
that i would rather be harassed like a
hundred times personally
than my parents be harassed once yeah
yeah you know what i mean like i just
couldn't because
they've got nothing to do with it why
did they have to get involved right it's
hard enough raising me as it was right
like let alone
the little [ __ ] that you are the little
[ __ ] that i was you know it's hard
enough
i don't want to have to give them extra
work after yeah he's trying to enjoy
retirement you know so
it's it's it's been kind of funny seeing
the transition between
like my parents at least because my
parents like really technologically
illiterate
and i've had to basically teach them
everything but it's been funny seeing
the transition between them
like not understanding social media at
all and just like
not using it at all and then
transitioning that to
like transitioning that to most of my
family now use facebook
right remember when facebook was just
like a cool kids thing
and like the parents their parents
didn't get it my parents
still didn't they still think it that
way
yeah because it was really funny because
i remember one day um
because i you know i've you know we are
all grown up on the internet and
especially
i've been doing youtube and social media
for like a long time
but one day my mum phones me up um and
this this was
this was when i had stopped using
facebook by this point i'd like most of
my online life has gone to twitter
because that's my job and everything
um but my parents had just started
really getting into facebook and you
know
being being that being that parents who
you know tag tag you in everything
comment on people's photos you know
properly involved yeah yeah
and i remember she phones me up one day
and she goes
uh gant um someone left a mean
comment on one of my photos what do i do
i'm just like what do you mean mom what
what do you mean what do you do
and she's like i i don't know what to do
it makes me feel
sad i kind of want to reply and i'm just
like
mom do not do not do this do not reply
right now
do not get involved that's the one thing
you should not do
it was just funny because um because
like years ago she was like
she's like you know just just just
ignore all the mean comments online and
just don't worry about it as you know as
the parents do because you know
as someone as as a parent watching a kid
do
social media and do youtube that you
just don't get it you see comments
you're just like
these comments don't mean anything right
yeah yeah but it was funny seeing
seeing my parents who had never been
into social media go through the same
cycle that we had to go
we had to go through being like what
what is a mean comment why are people
commenting mean things on me this
doesn't make
sense you know what i'm gonna reply i'm
going to give the trolls everything they
want
at least your mom wasn't like do you
know the number to the cyber police
i need to report a crime
no like my mom's like my mom's really
smart about it like because she's been
using uh
do you know about this website called
mixi i don't think it's any brand
anymore but basically it's like
it's really all web it's basically like
the old japanese version of like
uh myspace or like facebook and stuff
like that but i don't even think it's
around anymore basically my mom's been
like using that
so like she's had a pretty good
understanding of like
you know privacy can be very easily
leaked on the internet if you're not
careful
so like my mum has openly told me she's
like
yeah i follow you on twitter and
instagram but yeah you'll never know
which account is mine
[ __ ] it out that's some death note [ __ ]
she's like
like she's like because like she just
uses like you know a completely separate
name and like doesn't use any photos and
stuff like that and i'm like yeah i'm
glad that you know
she understands that you know if she
used her real face a name that could
lead to a whole lot of problems
me while my dad is like you know [ __ ]
openly comments on my videos and being
like that's my son
that's my boy no no i remember i
remember one time he's like
did you see the comment on my latest on
your latest video and i'm like
uh no i get i get thousands of comments
every day and he's like oh okay i'll
send you a screenshot of it
and it's like and he's like oh you might
have missed it because i don't use my
name on it
but instead he didn't use his name on it
right it's like a completely different
username
but i knew immediately it was my dad
because the comment starts with hey son
hey son i really like this video the
editing was done really well
it's like you'll never know it's me oh
yeah sure that's so [ __ ] wholesome i
don't know why that that's so [ __ ]
hot yeah but the problem
is is that like when i was still using
facebook back in the day
yeah like you know again like my mom
would use a completely like separate
name right so like you know it was fine
or whatever but my dad
would not only use his real name but
would also comment on
every [ __ ] thing i posted always
starting with hey son
so like hey guys joey's dad here yeah
and so like and so i had to like
and so like one day he came in being
like really upset at me being like
why did you block me on facebook son i'm
like because you keep [ __ ]
stop commenting oh stop stop opening a
comment with hey son
your dad sounds like such a fun guy no
he's a great guy don't get me wrong but
like i had to
i had to literally block him on every
social media just because
he kept [ __ ] doing that and now the
only
the number one harasser yeah and now the
only way i can get in contact with my
dad
is get this through email
because like a number or something you
know okay like i have his number or
whatever but like you know obviously
because it's international it costs a
bit of money right yeah and so
i was like hey dad you should start a
lion account because everyone in japan
has line
everyone in my family has a line right
yeah if you guys don't know that lion is
like you know
facebook messages it's just a messaging
app that we use in japan a lot so i was
like
you should start lying and he's like oh
i don't want to start on other social
medias and i'm like dad it's not a
social media it's just it's just a
messaging app and he's like all right
all right fine i'll do it
and so i added him and i messaged him
and it was like three months later he
came back being like what's up son
so now so i just like i was like all
right i guess i'm just sticking the
email now with my dad if my dad ever
needs anything i'll just be like just
email me
it's urgent i've got to email him right
now urgent hey son
[Laughter]
now every one of your comments on every
one of your videos
yeah yeah yeah no i guess that's good
there because then now i'll truly won't
know which one my dad is
the comment section is all gonna be my
dad he's gonna have to try and find
something like a new phrase to go with
like hey boy hey boy
i love you dad i'm just joshing but what
were we talking about internet privacy
i guess internet privacy i mean i don't
know like i've never
i i guess this is the first wake-up call
for me that i've had to really
think about my internet privacy it took
me way too long to make my facebook
uh my my facebook privates um that was
that should have been the first stage
but yeah
i think the problem with internet like
celebrities or whatever
nowadays is that there's a difference
between say
it's you know someone who's signed to a
big film or someone gets picked up by a
music label like old school celebrities
who
there was this system by which they got
picked up and they knew they were going
to be famous but the problem is anyone
can be famous now
anyone can have their privacy leaked and
you know
not really think about the consequences
of really going through their entire
[ __ ] past
and just making it private or you know
making it not public because
we were we were teenagers we don't
remember every [ __ ]
site that we signed up to oh my god like
i i don't know how many one of my like
old forum like old anime forum profile
pictures are still
like public or whatever you know because
i signed up to a lot of slides back then
because i was a teenager but
it's it's something that you you don't
really think about
when you don't make content on the
internet because you don't no one really
expects to be famous or no one really
expects to have
an audience or anything like that yeah
um and i feel like i i do wonder if
like the newer generation is going to
think about this when whenever
they do anything or if we're just going
to continue to be stupid kids that
i don't really think about anything i
would i would like
for it to be the first option if i'm
being honest just because like you know
again it's like
i i think that whole pre-notion of like
yeah you know you you should expect your
privacy to be
you know hacked and slashed yeah because
yeah yeah it's like it's like what is it
about suddenly being you know quote
unquote famous you know regardless of
how you view
you know fame to be where it's suddenly
like oh well you know you
you have a presence on the internet that
you share openly with a large audience
so that means that
you know you don't have a privacy if
it's on the internet it's not private
anymore it's literally like the same
argument as
like old-school paparazzi have you ever
seen any [ __ ] interviews with like
any paparazzi photographer
it's the most they're all [ __ ] yeah
it's it
it's the most like you see these people
openly being arseholes
and they're they're just they they're
proud of it
they're [ __ ] proud of it like i think
i remember the last one i saw was
i think anthony's like sitting down with
a paparazzi i thought yes
literally everyone he interviewed was
just the the biggest class they are sold
you know they do that whole [ __ ] of
like oh if i don't do it someone else is
gonna get it yeah it's like how about
none of you [ __ ] do it
and it sucks because like i think 99 of
people again who are watching this are
like super chill
don't but like think that way there's
all it takes that one percent to make
your life happen
yeah yeah like and that's unfortunate
right because you know i i don't i don't
have any resentment to mine like
audience or anything like that i don't
know most of them are super [ __ ] nice
exactly just a [ __ ] shame that some
people are just like i'm a [ __ ]
ruin this man's life yeah it's a shame
that you know you have to change your
behavior
for literally one percent of the people
watching you and you know that most
most of everyone that you interact with
is just going to be a generally nice
cool person yeah and then it just sucks
that there's that small percentage that
unfortunately it's it's that small
percentage that ruins it for everyone
and it's i guess i guess that's just the
world in general right yeah
yeah yeah but you know we'd be living in
the utopia if everyone was being honest
and kind of
flying cars we're not flying cars by now
that's not the case right now some of us
are still walking on the ground
so yeah big sad i was i was watching
this video the other day
and it was like um it's not blue's clues
blue or not blues
trust me this is related back to the
show okay okay so
did you watch blue's clues when you're
growing up of course what's blue's clues
all right so blues clues this tv show
and especially this guy
who was like talking to the camera kind
of like dora style
this is where it started this kind of
style i maybe didn't know but i'm
definitely popularized where there would
be like a a task
and there was this you know a notebook
and they'd have to do x amount of tasks
it was a really good show actually
there was a dog called blue yeah okay
yeah and so that you the dog would help
uh steve steve steve find all the clues
right
and um yeah so i always wondered i was
like why did he stop doing it because if
you if you watch the show
he basically swaps halfway through the
show with another actor
i thought oh that's where's weird why
did that happen so it turns out
that uh he was losing his hair and that
he didn't want to like go bald on like
tv right okay right right so
and then i was like [ __ ] that hit me i
was like oh my god
[ __ ] cause like i mean okay there's like
tons of comments about it and it's like
it's frustrating because like i don't
really give a [ __ ] anymore like
i've gotten over it but like
unfortunately my dad did not give me a
lucky dice roll with my genetics and i
am going bald eventually
it's gonna happen and obviously it's
been happening a little bit
and it's so frustrating that people will
like go to other videos and be like
connor
yeah did you know you're balding and i'm
like keep pointing it out yeah it's like
and it's so frustrating because the
thing that bothers me is that like again
like i fully accepted that it's
happening i know people are gonna be
like have you tried doing this have you
tried [ __ ]
doing voodoo and it's like yes
because people are always like hey just
just try pushing the ball because people
always like hey man just take these
drugs do these things like yeah okay
i've honestly like done all that tried
all that yeah unfortunately like
i can't do surgery either so whatever so
i just kind of got to the point where i
was like all right i think i've tried
enough things or i'm like
this [ __ ] sucks yeah but it can't
really do much about it
right yeah and so i kind of got over it
but it's really frustrating like i said
when people go to other videos and be
like bro you're balding it's like yeah
like like i'm i am aware but it's
frustrating
that sometimes i feel like edit videos
differently because it's like all right
if i don't edit this part out people are
going to comment about this
instead of the [ __ ] video and only
comment about it yeah it's like it's
like i just want to focus on the video
and it's so frustrating people feel they
need to point it out yeah
it's like why like yeah yeah i mean i i
know exactly how you feel
because i too have not been luckiest
with my gene pool so like
joey i envy your perfect hair so like
um so like pretty much everyone on my
dad's side who's a male
yeah same with the same yeah it's kind
of nice it's something that i knew was
always going to happen we don't think
it's going to happen i mean yeah yeah
like as as like when you're when you're
a teenager you're like i'm just like
i'm i'm i'm the exception your hair's
like your hair's like when you're like
18 your hair's like warm it's
lost yeah [ __ ] man my hair's so sick as
[ __ ] and i'm just like you think i'm the
exceptional girl
and i remember um you know i've seen
like my entire family on my dad's side
everyone's everyone's bold so i asked my
dad
i've seen like pictures of my dad when
he was young and he had hair down to
here man he's bad yeah yeah he was
dripping um but yeah
yeah he had a he had a [ __ ] luscious
hair
yeah and i saw what it looks like now
and i'm just like so um
dada when when did you start losing your
hair just just just
out of curiosity so just so i can take a
look and uh take a look at my own hair
and he goes
um i guess late 20 30 year old and i
asked this when i was 28 i was like
[ __ ] why did you not tell me earlier for
[ __ ] sakes yes
yo this is like i i can't i hadn't i had
a feeling like
it's probably gonna happen to me right
but like i i didn't like quite know
but then i realized okay my older
brother who's like 10 years older than
me was going bold and i was
like oh [ __ ] she's starting to sweat a
lot all right
[Music]
yeah and like i you know what i totally
get why kids think it's funny to like
mock
hairlines because you just think like
it's never gonna happen yeah yeah i've
got hair my hair is [ __ ] luscious
right now it's never gonna happen
but it does oh yeah what is it like
[ __ ] two out of three
especially if you're white i think two
out of three men get like some signs of
hair loss or whatever all right
yeah but i remember like i thought okay
if it happens to me at 30 no biggie
you know it's by then i'll probably be
chilling out i'll be settling down
when i was like 21 or like 20 i started
to notice just a little bit it's getting
a little bit thin and i'm like
right what's going on up there huh
better put a timeout
so even when i was like 20 i started
like trying to do things to like help it
was
doing those like you know taking it all
the [ __ ] fda approved all that
[ __ ] yeah yeah yeah yeah but
unfortunately
for some people it is purely just
genetics yeah you just [ __ ] like some
people
that helps and like you know you do a
lot of research you look into it
some guys you might be in a place where
maybe the building you're living in is
like really bad case of like damp or
something that's [ __ ] with your like
your hair right
right so some people who you know their
living conditions are the reason why
they're losing their hair yeah
no unfortunately as much as i wish that
i could do something about it it was
just kind of like
whatever and it's it's yeah i guess the
the main
reason why i just thought [ __ ] it i'll
just talk about it because it's like
i've gotten to the point now right
people are pointing out anyway
it's it's like it's not going to stop
yeah yeah i feel like if we just say
something yeah facebook can at least be
uh
especially with a growing audience right
like new york are going to come into
being like oh this is the inside meme
okay
i'll add on to it for the millionth time
yeah because you know it's like
unfortunately it's just kind of a thing
of like
you know it's just something that i i
can't really do anything about and
unfortunately people are going to see it
you know because i'm not like i'm not
unfortunately not gonna you're not gonna
wear a hat every day yeah my videos
aren't just me statically in front of
the camera never moving my head so it's
like how do you guys
you can't go anything further than like
a 90 degree angle otherwise
that's a red zone yeah yeah and it was
like so when i dyed my hair
blonde it wasn't that bad because my
scalp is like white
yeah yeah so it didn't look that bad but
it's when it starts to go brown and
certain lighting like especially studio
lighting
[ __ ] reflects that [ __ ] yeah yeah so
where it doesn't look too bad if you
look at me like normally
in like video where the lighting is
washed out it looks [ __ ]
awful yeah right and it's like when i
see it on video i'm like [ __ ] it
that bad i check it i'm like oh it's not
too bad like that's what happened yeah
yeah yeah but
i'm pretty much at peace with it and
i'll probably shave it at some point
because i kind of want to see how it
look
yeah i reckon you're good
like you have you have you lucked out
though in that regards because
the one thing no no like the one thing
is like you know like the fact that
you've already accepted that you're
probably going to go bored and like you
probably already know
whatever but at least the good thing is
is that you can grow a beard
yeah yeah there is nothing weirder than
a dude
who is bald and has a clean face why are
you doing my boy johnny sims like that
man come on man
he's got the biggest dick in the
industry yeah sure and you know and
that's why he
like you know yeah i can't say that in
front of johnny sims right because he
probably smacked
particularly across my face
but like you know at least like you know
a beard on a bald guy
usually nine times out of ten looks
[ __ ] great yeah yeah
you look you look hard as [ __ ] dude i
appreciate you trying to gasp me up here
jay
yeah yeah yeah no no but like that's
once but like it's weird because like
you know you you said like you know i'm
jealous of you joy but like i actually
had the opposite because like
i have too much hair i have too much
what a problem guys
because my because like your entire
dad's side right
dude they're like i think my dad was
born like [ __ ] 20 yeah
see my mom's side is exactly the same
because my granddad went bold at like
24.
yeah so for the longest time in my like
early 20s
my mom and my sister would just [ __ ]
egg me on being like when are you gonna
get that hair
you better enjoy that hair while you
still have it on your head boy and i'm
the head of
all the hairline's receding a bit yeah
and like i would like i remember when i
was like 18 i like asked my granddad
being like how old were you when you
like started to go to the ball and he
was like oh like
like 23 and i was like that's like five
years for me
[ __ ] but you know obviously i at that
point i was like
look if i go bald [ __ ] it i'll just
accept it you know like
i'd rather just like shave it all off
then like leave it half fast right so
i'm just like [ __ ] it
the more i thought about it and um the
more because i i can't actually get any
surgery even i wanted to because i have
my like a blood condition yeah yeah the
more i thought about i was like do i
do i really want to just [ __ ]
desperately cling on to this like at the
end of the day i was like i don't really
think i give that much for a [ __ ] where
i think i need my hair to function yeah
like i think i'll still be fine without
it
right that's the thing right like i
don't understand why people love people
people make it seem like if you lose
your hair it's gone because it's like
a bold person right right i sleep
someone with full hair i sleep
balding free real estate for bullying
is where it's at yeah i don't know
because people i feel like people just
want to have like at least some comments
out there i feel like they need to have
like a one-up on you they don't feel
like they can mock you in some way but
like
but they but they keep mentioning it
like as if like oh if you lose your hair
you're not funny anymore like
was making fun of like something to do
with like genetics like a [ __ ]
slammed out to me i was like
it's like you you you you know you take
the piss out someone's look no no no too
far
boarding yeah oh free
yeah like like it's the same thing
you're taking a piss out of what someone
was born with right like
i do notice like as you know as as
someone who went through
the phase of you know like just
accepting that they were bolding you
know you do go through that
five stages you do you just there is
like the first few
i think year or two when it's happening
you're like no i can i can reverse this
i can
i can reverse this five stages of bald
english yeah i mean i think you do right
now
and i'm sure this conversation is quite
close to home to a lot of our viewers
because our audience is mainly dudes
yeah yeah if it is happening to you
don't give a [ __ ] man it's whatever just
whatever you're wrong i mean
you can do whatever you want it's not
like society [ __ ] rejects you yeah
because yeah
you know i feel like you know some
people are you know i i for one i have
been bored before
um i do i do
man yeah but i i do like my hair and you
know i am putting in steps to
you know i i don't expect to keep this
forever but i would like to
elongate it for as long as i can you
know i'm like me too
i'm self-aware enough to know that you
know once it's past the point
all right yeah i got it too far it's
gone but at least at least right now
when i still have this hair i'm gonna be
like okay you know i'm gonna lose this
eventually yeah
but i am going to try and do my best at
this point to just keep it and i don't
think
there's anything particularly wrong
about it there's no there's nothing
particularly wrong
with either direction that you go to all
right i think it's more just
you know i some some people i you know i
like the feeling of having hair i like
the feeling
i like the feeling of you know washing
your hair and
my god especially [ __ ] one thing that
nobody tells you about being bold
right it's cold right it's [ __ ] cold
okay
you're you're either cold or if you're
in a hot humid country like
thailand [ __ ] mosquitoes it's free
real estate
there's an extra surface area for the
mosquitoes just go [ __ ] mental
i i do it's like a park that just
bathing experience which is like your
bathing type is like cut by half
and like when you get out bro you're
immediately dropped that sounds amazing
you know how like you know
hurry i am a single wife and also like
do you use i mean shampoo is irrelevant
right yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
you save so much money dude what the
[ __ ] well i hate having to find like
organic [ __ ] shampoo that isn't like
full of like sulfates or something yeah
yeah yeah but i mean yeah as well i did
have this thought i was like you know
what
it's like i don't know if this is creepy
or what to some people but i think it's
kind of [ __ ] cool that like
my whole adult life is like captured in
like youtube
like you can see like my whole like
there'll be like 19. you can see you can
see the
progress yeah you'll be like 19 year old
me that is like spots and like [ __ ]
yeah pepperoni face and then yeah in
like 10 years you'll see me like
it's it's the glow up actually yeah i
think i think it's kind of like i don't
know i think it's kind of fascinating
that i can have like a you know as
cringe as it might be i can have like a
backlog
because what i what i find interesting
right is
you know we i don't know what it was
like for your parents but my parents are
like pretty old right now so there's not
too many photos of
when they were younger and like my age
especially
so you know i see photos here and then
you're just like damn that's what you
looks like
yeah like okay but for you know when we
have kids
we have like our entire lives just like
documented but that's that's true for
most people
like even above like being youtubers you
got facebook photos going back to like
my my kid will definitely know my entire
life up to like
um university yeah like there are some
uni photos where i'm just like
damn son or daughter i don't know if i
want you going through this man
yeah i don't know if it's a good bad
thing i pretty much purged i lost a lot
of my photos pre-18 like on facebook i
pushed most of them
yeah because i hated how i looked in
them yeah like [ __ ] it i mean no one
likes how they looked yeah put that yeah
and i thought should i keep them and i
was like no i'm getting rid of them so i
actually i've lost a lot of them i
pretty much have like i would say an
average amount of like that anyone would
have
someone who took photos right yeah but i
think it's cool as an adult i can make
the choice to be like i'm fine with
having most of my like adult life
yeah essentially be documented i think
that's kind of cool
i mean whether my future kids think so
yeah he's like
that's up to them i'm sorry for any
future kid who goes through my twitter
timeline
god i'm so [ __ ] sorry i'm sure
twitter at some point
will do like a big purge of life you
think so
because how can you store all that [ __ ]
the sponsor of today's episode is
ej anime store what has ej sample got
i've never said this before but ej anime
store stands for entertainment japan
whoa
i didn't know that and if you don't know
what ej anime stories it is kaduka's
official online anime merch store that
specializes in delivering the newest and
most exclusive official anime merch to
overseas fans
directly from japan such as these that
are on the table right now look at them
what do we got today connor wow i'm glad
you asked scott
we have the connor super mega minion
union what the hell is a yonion
the megamin and union light novel
chinese style dress versions
inspired by a set of illustrations
created specifically by the corner super
light novel illustrator
kurone mishima to celebrate union's
character birthday the kalikawa special
set each include a rubber desk mat for
illustrations that inspired these
figures as an exclusive bonus i love
conor subagant but what else do we have
well for the cultured individuals out
there that's me
we have the redo of healer freya and
sets in the light novel versions
i can't actually believe that they made
figurines i'm surprised
i'm actually shocked that they made
figurines and they're good
okay ej anime store brings you the two
main heroines of the show
that has gotten a lot of attention this
season it definitely has gotten a lot of
attention this season let's be sure
let's be real enjoy these cultured
representations of freya and cessna that
include additional exchangeable face
parts and were inspired by a set of new
original illustrations created by the
original light novel illustrator shio
kombu the katakawa special set each
includes a fabric poster of the
illustrations that inspired these
figures as an exclusive
bonus guys but we can't forget the bang
dream girl band party
rosalia yukina minetto pajama version go
check out all these items on ej
animestore.com while they're still
available
or click the link in the description and
if you haven't already
follow them on facebook and twitter at
ej anime store so you don't miss any of
their giveaways and limited time
offers thank you dj animus thor for
sponsoring this episode back to the show
no i think they can because i mean that
just means like that youtube
you know all the youtube videos in the
world have a finite shelf life and
basically every media
and every big website in the world has a
finite shelf life right
yeah surely so i don't know i i like
like you said like when it comes to
online media i kind of act like a
hoarder right
like i don't know what i could look like
yeah exactly
i don't know what i could look back in a
few years and be like yeah
i tweeted that back in 2008 or
i couldn't remember when i started my
twitter man it's been it's been a while
i didn't even know twitter was that old
to be honest
yeah yeah because i have i have this
thing on i don't know if you have it i
think you do right
where like i have this thing on my
twitter where like if the tweet is older
than two months then it automatically
deletes it right i think that mine's set
like two years just because like
every time i look back at myself two
years i'm like [ __ ] that's cringy yeah
yeah but i'm like that six months ago so
i'm just like
i like the ability to look back and be
like man i was [ __ ] cringy
i like the ability to look back and go
man what the [ __ ] was this was this
anime zone hairstyle
what the [ __ ] man i got that on youtube
yeah
that's what the youtube channel is for
the twitch clips you know all that [ __ ]
that's what that's for yeah yeah yeah i
already have like one website to like
remind me of how cringy i used to be
i want like multiple websites to remind
me how cringy i used to be
i want to know what [ __ ] cringey
thoughts i had you know that's that's
it's not just pictures i want everything
like i don't want to go back on like my
my personal facebook and then go back to
like you know 2010 and being like oh god
why the [ __ ] did i tweet
[ __ ] out like that or message [ __ ] out
like that but no because uh going back
to the bold conversation
yeah and like rock rocking and style and
everything like that so i remember i
had to go through this exact process
when i finished being a monk
yeah and i i was just i was just bold
right and we talked about before how you
know you can't you can't really
it's hard to rock a bold style
when you don't have a beard or anything
i i feel like it's especially hard as an
asian as well
right so like initially all i did was
just like wear it like
wear a beanie and the thing the thing
about this like frail
asian kid wearing a beanie walking
around you look like a [ __ ] cancer
patient
like that's that's you know that's
that's that's
that's kind of like what i look like on
the outside so i was like i'm tired of
this
you know i i want to at least i want to
change my style right
there right so i was thinking well what
can i possibly do
and the only other style i can think of
is like what what do you think of when
you think you know
bold head shaved you think you kind of
you kind of you kind of think of like
someone who just like a delinquent right
someone's
yeah like a skin head right so
i tried to go for that look and i i have
a picture actually
i i i i dug this up
during the break let me see if i can get
it but yeah i went for
i went for the skinhead look and for the
first for the first and only time in my
life
i looked like a complete whoa i look
like i just came out of prison man
like asian adjacent statement
it's the this is the first and only time
in my life where
i felt dangerous right so i i would
i would be like i would be walking down
i will move away from you no exactly i
would be because i was living in china
at this time right
and so i would be walking down the
streets and sometimes if
if it was it was dark you know i could
see like
groups of girls or groups of anyone just
like subtly cross the road whenever i
was approaching
i was like okay and this this one time
so i was with some friends then it took
me like to this local bar who's
run by this like frail you know you know
one of the
old asian ladies who run this local bar
yeah
and so we walk in and uh she dead ass
looks at me and i could see her have
like a mini
a mini [ __ ] heart attack she's like
what and then
she goes to my mate and goes um sorry
we're closed right now i'm amazed like
no i i've been here quite often
um i you know i know this place is open
and she dead are says to him
i'm just not looking for trouble right
now oh
god's the kind of guy when you say i'm
not looking for trolls
i don't blame you man like if i if i was
that frail already i thought
i would think i would look at that and
be like oh that's chinese were you
wearing the sunglasses
and the scarf as well i was wearing the
scarf yeah that's chinese mafia dude
i mean i'm not dealing with that [ __ ]
yeah the scarf says like
it's louis but i mean you know i kill
people as well
the scarf says
it felt like you know that meme of that
guy in the party being like
they don't know i'm a fair anime man i
don't know i killed people
it's like the big coat as well it's like
yeah i might be concealing a weapon but
i'll never sell this is honestly the
first time i ever like tried wearing a
leather jacket and i'm just like
damn you know what you're not good in
leather jackets is that why you wear
leather jackets a lot nowadays ever
since then this is what started it i
want to scoot on you
yeah you're the only one i know where
it's like damn he [ __ ] kills a
leather jacket
because i've seen so many people growing
up who are like oh you know i want to i
want to get back into like the whole
like 80s like street west
you know the punk spirit and like wear a
leather jacket and it's just
it looks so lame some people do look
like they're just wearing their dad's
clothes yeah right
yeah especially with another jacket yeah
i tried it once and i was like
nah it's not for me yeah for me the one
piece of clothing i find really hard to
rock
is a good suit i don't know i don't know
i don't know what it is about a suit
right
um love wearing suits yeah i know you
love wearing suits you you use every
opportunity you can
you just rock up when you're jojo's like
we'll go to the grocery store
why not suits are so fun to wear man it
is it is really fun
you feel like you commend a presence
when you're wearing a suit you know like
when i
when i leave my house around the jojo
suit like like you know like
i go on the train i'm like yeah [ __ ]
yeah i'm wearing this because like for
me
like i can rock a suit but it really
needs to be tailor made because like
anything else if
most like my entire life if i just buy
like this store made suit you know
it feels it just feels like i'm wearing
my dad's clothes i
i look like five years younger and i and
that's not a good it's not a good five
years younger it looks like i'm back to
being a teenager
yeah i don't know especially as well
here if you wear anything other than the
standard businessman suit here which is
like what the navy
like the navy blue white t-shirt
underneath it's like not really navy
it's like dark
navy like they they all wear the same
goddamn suit so when i you know when i
whip out
my little like i don't know burgundy
what color is it like beige
it's like the jojo beige suit it stands
out so [ __ ] much
one right yeah and i'm like yeah you've
you i'm like yeah [ __ ]
i know it's hard like i forget sometimes
you have you bought two jojo's because
you only wear that one
yeah because because the other one is
like way more formal
so it's a little harder to wear it like
on like just kind of like not super
serious yeah yeah cause i i've got the
other one the butcherarty one yeah
like the navy blue like kind of a little
more standard looking one
it's also like a crossover and i feel
like the crossover is like more mafia
more like super serious whereas the
jonno one cause it's just like super
chill it's like bay
beige is not a serious color no people
who are beige don't do serious things
you can look good explain serious things
like
i don't know you see someone wearing
this suit like people like mafia members
here is the john no suit here is the
bucharati suit right the bucharati suit
looks like you you are killing people
you're trading in stocks that can't be
bought by public citizens you know
the jonah one looks like you know like
you like you have fun times you go out
for nice meals you know
it's you know it's a different kind of
atmosphere yeah i go to the girls bar
every now and then
it's a different kind of atmosphere that
it gives off right
it's like wearing a three-piece you
can't just casually wear a three piece
but i love wearing three i love wearing
it you look
so [ __ ] good in the three piece
because i don't something
you know i i like how men's fashion no
matter how
how much time is passed right a suit and
a three piece just always looks good
yeah that it's just something that is
timeless and i don't know what it is
they've just
like we we optimized how good guys could
look like
hundreds of years ago uh and then it
just hasn't changed since then yeah yeah
the standard has always been the same
i remember i don't really spend much
money on clothes but obviously
suit's quite expensive yeah and anyone
who's bought bought a suit will know
that
like a nice suit yeah like a nice suit
right like yeah you can go to primark
and get the 20
suits or whatever and it doesn't look
bad actually yeah it doesn't yeah i
remember i was telling like i was
talking about on
on twitch i was talking about the jojo
suits because they're bringing out new
jojo suits and i'm like yeah i'm going
to buy them all they were like the part
four ones right
four ones yeah and they're like they're
like 500 bucks each and i'm like listen
guys
for a suit 500 bucks is not that much
especially if you can go in there and
get they tailor it a little bit to you
like i said come on this these suits are
[ __ ] gorgeous especially as an adult
as well like that's just gonna last
yeah bro you think i'm i'm only ever
wearing those jojo suits now it's a
one-time thing
i'm never wearing i'm never wearing any
other suits ever right
i mean pretty well but you know i mean i
might get my [ __ ] money's worth right
and also they're nice things they're
luxurious man you gotta like you know
a good suit you can't cheap out if you
go to a job interview wearing a cheap
ass suit
come on yeah come on i mean you go to a
job interview wearing a jojo suit
bro they're like an application presence
has been commanded when i
you know you walk in right this boy is
serious at his beige
he's balding never mind he's got a jojo
yeah he's got a beige suit on he's good
i mean that's the thing about the suit
is that it's one of it's one of the few
things that you really can't cheap out
on them no you can't
you can try i mean like you know you can
go to places like you can get a pretty
cheap suit in somewhere like thailand
that's like tailor-made and everything
like that but
if you don't have that luxury of buying
of going to a place where it can be made
for cheap then
a cheap suit really shows like almost
like
you can feel it when you wear it as well
yeah when it's a good suit you feel like
damn
i'm powerful it comes off in the aura
that you give off
it's like some hunter hunter men stuff
right you're like people can feel your
presence when you
when you're in a good suit people know
you aren't a good suit they feel it in
the way that you act
i'm telling you man it's not [ __ ]
that's what that's what i do when i go
by soon i'm just like excuse me is the
aura tailored in
honestly honestly
you you know it's too tailor-made when
they're asking questions you're like
what the [ __ ] you talking about
they're like they're asking you stuff
like would you like this or that i'm
like i've never been asked that question
in my life what is that
then they show you like i don't care
what do you think you're the tailor you
tell me it's like would you like two
centimeters or three centimeters off
your cuff
it's like [ __ ] i don't know yeah like
when the ass like do you want the leg
rolled up at the bottom yeah i was like
i don't know just
tell me what looks good i i literally
have no [ __ ] what do you what do you
tell me because i remember like the
first time i wore a suit was
for like my high school prom or
something i think that was the first
time that everybody
yeah you get like the primarks yeah your
parents are not buying you a good suit
because
you're not going to get any value out of
it yeah little [ __ ] and everyone
everyone does look like they're wearing
yeah right i think it's impossible
it's like that oversized suits oh god
it looks so unnatural good the good old
days where you just
get away why is that every like 16 year
old who goes like their first prom in a
suit just looks like they're just
like because you're not comfortable yeah
but like it's it's so funny how like
every photo i've ever seen either of
myself or of my friends or
just complete random strangers at their
problems they all look like they're
t-posing
you know what i mean they're like they
all they all look like they're just
standing like yes we are out of prom
is like fifty percent of the suit fifty
percent how comfortable you feel wearing
yeah yeah can you embody what a suit is
you know you can't just put on a suit
and be like i guess i'm i guess i'm kind
of like
yeah attractive now no you got to
believe that when you put that suit on
yeah i'm hot
yeah you're gonna give off that aura
you're gonna have faith but like
okay there's there's always this there's
always like every time i wear a suit
right
there's always this countdown of like
when am i going to take this jacket off
because inevitably
when you go to like any celebrations or
something you're going to get too hot in
that so yeah
of course of course and i i feel like
you know if you're going to take
pictures or do anything
get it right at the beginning of the
night because yeah there's there's
nothing more messier than like just the
suit that you know has just been
battered and damaged and like you can
tell
it's it's not the suit itself it's the
tie right yeah like at the beginning
you're like you got
you're buttoned up right to the top
button your tie is tight you look
[ __ ] suave
yeah five hours in god you're a sweaty
mess that tie
has taken a beating it's like it's like
halfway down your chest
one thing japan is like advanced
technology in is like their business
shirts are like next level yeah like
i've i don't know how they've done it
but japan has like optimized the [ __ ]
out of like shirts like business [ __ ]
like of course they have because
everyone every
everyone's wearing every other person
here is a salary man yeah yeah i mean i
put this thing on at first and it was a
little pricey i thought
you know i mean i guess you know from
buying a nice suit i'll buy a nice
shirt it's always an afterthought cause
i always think if it's white who gives a
[ __ ]
then i put this thing on i'm like whoa
it breathes it stretches it looks clean
it washes super easy and i'm like whoa
i've never like appreciated
a shirt until japan i remember i
remember i saw an ad for like uh
like last summer yeah when it was like
you know that [ __ ] heat wave game
yeah
yeah and like it doesn't matter if it's
like 40 degrees or it's four degrees
people are wearing a suit the material
feels amazing but i remember i saw an ad
which dead i said like
this business shirt has self-cooling
technology
i get it there's like cooling technology
and i'm like
it's a it's a piece of cotton some of
them like have like a stretchiness to it
that
makes it like feel really like aerated i
don't know what it is okay if you come
to japan right and you like
your shirt yeah dead ass you know [ __ ]
bringing my
anime figures get some [ __ ] japanese
shirts
go to like perfect suit factory here and
just go and put get go get some biceps
yeah that's self-calling
they're legit they're good i feel like
whenever japan like advertises this new
fancy technology and clothing though
it's it's it's hit or miss because
sometimes you get good things like the
heat tech here
the heat tech when you go to uniqlo and
it's winter those are [ __ ] great yeah
yeah
every kind of cool shirts you know every
cold cafe yeah the the cooling shirts
obviously great
i remember though recently like uniqlo
also released the they
you know this was deep during the
pandemic it was debuting during
quarantine they released like their own
uh aries and masks or something like
that that was meant
that was meant to like be more
breathable fabric
or something like that and um and it got
so hyped that it sold out on the first
day immediately
people were queuing up to buy these
masks and i think around
three months into it i was at uniqlo and
miraculously they were just back on sale
they just come back into stock so i was
like you know i'm going to give this a
try because this has been sold out and
i'm i'm tired of my you know of like of
my mask so
let's let's see how breathable this is
um and
it literally it literally felt like you
just worn like you know one of those
like anime knickers
yeah yeah it literally just felt like
you had underwear in your face
and it was a [ __ ] lie it this thing
was this thing this thing felt like it
was going to give me asthma
it was not breathable at all yeah they
have a lot of fats there here and it's
very
fat technology yeah wasn't there that
like the uh
necklace or something that was meant to
prevent yeah literally i see some people
wearing it's called virus out
yeah just like a literally just like a
necklace
and everyone's wearing it yeah aki made
like an entire video about like a bunch
of like coronavirus scam items and
one of them was that it's like it's like
this [ __ ] lucky charm looking thing
where it's like
go away virus it was literally that
energy
it's just like it's just it's just a
[ __ ] like car air freshener around
your neck
that's all it is like i'd rather you not
care than have that and be like i care
yeah right
because because like at least you're not
pretending at that point yeah yeah yeah
but like the fact that they're like i
saw a bunch of people who like like
especially like older like women
who you know always believe in that [ __ ]
for some reason who would like wear that
and be like
well i don't have to wear a mask anymore
yeah i'm fully protected with
this you know i mean it's the same
reason [ __ ] anti-vaxxers and stuff
like exists right because this kind of
you know if
you have if we have a small small enough
group who traded not trade information
within that group
um then they're just going to start
believing the wilder [ __ ] sometimes
and you know it's a lot of like the
image globally is that a lot of people a
lot of this is
confined to america but you know it's
all over it's it's all over it's all
over the world like
it's definitely it is all over the place
it's just stupidity's not confined by
one type of like nationality just the
big difference is
like it seems in america it's just more
documented and it's more widespread yeah
yeah it's unfortunate because like i
mean like you said like the stupid i do
agree they are stupid
but it's been like proven right if you
keep calling them stupid it like makes
them
believe in it more yeah yeah you're like
you've got you're like you're a
conspiracy you're like
you're on the internet are you working
with the government you're one of them
but also at the same time i don't want
to sit there and humor [ __ ] stupid
ideas yeah
so it's like yeah i don't know i don't i
don't really talk about it i don't
really get involved with it because i'm
just like
i feel like it's a loose lose these
people should know better yeah you know
i i just like to think that
you know like for example if my mum one
day got into something like that that
i'd like to be able to think that i
could maybe talk her out of it like mum
yeah yeah come on
yeah the pg tips is not poison you can
drink the tea in them
i'm pretty sure we'd all be dead with it
you know you know just giving you a fake
yeah yeah
yeah it's unfortunate wasn't it like the
[ __ ] in
in england what like the 5g towers
caused that was
embarrassing that was like coconut or
whatever it was here
that was like huge in the uk yeah that
people were like burning down these
towers yeah it's embarrassing
you're like these are like i live in the
same country these people i went to the
same schools
yeah there's these people who burned
down [ __ ] 5g towers
there's also that fat of like you know
you should you shouldn't like when when
wireless uh like bluetooth headphones
first came out for your phone
people should use those because if you
if you're on the phone like this then
the signal
actually i remember that yeah i remember
that yeah
and there were people at least in
australia like when i was growing up
there were like people dead ass
being like [ __ ] i have to go and buy
some bluetooth headphones you know
i don't i don't want to get a tumor in
my brain from all these phone calls i'm
taking i'm like
what are you on i think one of the most
interest
uh interesting things i've like i've
seen happen recently that's happened
right in front of my eyes is the [ __ ]
toilet paper shortage
right like like i think back to that
and like what does that feel like 10
years ago i know
but like i think back to that and like
our kids are going to be reading about
this or like they're going to see like
it's next they're going to see the
internet historian video like [ __ ]
20 years in the future and be thinking
like ha ha my generation were never this
stupid
it's like i'm just imagining like you
know 20 years from now like our kids
right
we'll be like in [ __ ] history class
like modern history being like yeah all
right
class so today we're going to be talking
about the 2020 great
toilet paper shortage
like it's the same as the [ __ ] great
depression it blew my mind how in japan
it happened as well i'm like we
literally have [ __ ] bidets
it blew my mind what do you guys clean
your ass it blew my mind that it
happened
worldwide it was literally like a idea
that spread worldwide even though like
nobody nobody knew
where it came from oh no no
like the thing is nobody like in other
countries really knew that it came from
australia because they were just like
oh toilet paper i must buy i'm not i
don't know why but everyone else is
buying toilet paper therefore i must buy
toilet paper
it didn't occur to people that maybe
like you know if everyone just keeps
using toilet paper at the same rate that
we've all been using it
it'll continue to be the same right like
because
i don't know why because it was out of
every household necessity that you think
would happen
that you think people would need an
apocalypse food water
i sleep toilet paper i wake yeah this is
the real [ __ ]
so what did people think that like if
you got covered you also got irritable
bowel syndrome like
in my mind as well i'm like do i really
want to be an [ __ ] who just goes and
like
[ __ ] takes everything in the shop i'm
like ah i mean i'll i'll take like a
little bit of like pasta a little bit of
canned goods yeah nothing crazy
yeah i mean you know like we like we
stocked up yeah but we didn't [ __ ]
like be like can i have
everything on that shelf from there to
there no we we we only stocked up just
because
there was a literal shortage and there
was a little point where
i had trouble wiping my ass because
there wasn't there was no toilet paper
you know i was i was gonna clean my ass
with a bidet but i wasn't gonna
step out with a weird ass right like
[ __ ] that [ __ ] i just jiggle you know
a little shake because it was the one
piece of like everyday household
equipment there you know you can
understand soap you know okay i
understand yeah there would be a
shortage of soap i can understand hand
sanitizer of course i understand why
there would be
food and water food and water there
wasn't any i'm like do you know how easy
it is to live like rice or pasta
like you don't need much of that but
there was even a shortage of like pasta
as well like
i remember yeah yeah they're actually i
remember i remember the video of uh i
think it was in italy
there there was like all of this
supermarkets yeah they're like
and the old guy was like getting pissed
off that there was no pastor in the
supermarket and he was like
people weren't even this obsessed during
world war two
we had more pass through world war ii
than we do now what the [ __ ] going on
yeah i guess the problem is that like
everyone's telling each other you should
panic like in real time right
spread it yeah it's like oh my god i
don't know i had a bunch of cup ramen
and i was like i'm pretty i think i'm
good
yeah i'll see what happens like i'm
pretty sure the stores aren't just gonna
shut
yeah i i like there would be an exact
point
where i would like start panicking and
that exact point
is if i found out the kombini was closed
because like i i feel like
here if the combination closes you're
going through some real [ __ ] that is
when i'm truly watching
okay how are we really going through an
apocalypse okay i wake now
i'm [ __ ] yeah it's like america
they're like waffle house
and like you can judge on like the
disaster based on whether waffle house
is open or closed
it's like it's an actual like study like
thing
where like even when there's like
hurricanes yeah
waffle house in america is still open
wow
seriously yeah seriously look it up it's
really interesting like i think i
don't know which big natural disaster it
was i think it was a katrina or
something like yeah
it was still open like
because they're all equipped with like
generators right why
in case disasters yeah they're like one
of the only things that like will try
their best to stay open unless like
you know the disaster is so bad yeah
when waffle house in america like damn
my roof just got blown off
i could kill for some waffles right now
if like windows and [ __ ] are broken i
think they'll still continue to be open
like they'll let you in
like i i i'm not i'm not sure exactly i
could be chatting out my ass but
it's as far as i'm concerned anyways
because i i think
what this entire situation has made me
realize is i i remember
like oh before before 2020 watching like
old school
zombie movies and something like that
and you think to yourself man they made
the they made the people really stupid
in this
zombie movie this would never happen in
real life and now i look back and i'm
just
like definitely gonna happen i'm like
they didn't make them stupid enough
jesus christ
there'll be a sect of people that like
rounds up people and feeds them to the
zombies because if they think it'll
probably appease the zombie or something
there'll be some [ __ ] like that
there'll be something like that i look
at something like dead rising and i'm
like well this is unrealistic there's
still things inside all of the stores
the toilet paper is still a little bit
what the [ __ ]
there isn't a subgroup of people
praising the zombies what's going on
i i i i am curious what every like
zombie
story and like every like every kind of
like apocalyptic story
like would like how if 2020 would have
changed like how cliches and trolls are
just going to get a million
[ __ ] boring movies about this current
pandemic and
you know can you make an exciting movie
about the pandemic i don't care i mean
they tried to do it with 2012 right
they made one like in 2006 or something
like
that oh it was pandemic right that was a
little pandemic there's like a few
movies that like
that are like worryingly close to like
what happened yeah that was the there
was the one that i
that went viral i think i saw it last
year um
it was like crazy yeah yeah like in the
movie there was like a pandemic
that was like completely obviously named
something completely differently years
before
and uh and i think it got viral because
people
found it on netflix and started watching
it and the
dead asked the plot is that there was a
virus that was started
in china through that really yeah
and people were like yeah some chef had
it and he shook hands with a business
woman yeah and then and then it spread
to america and then like
half of americans [ __ ] mad i think
and people are like oh my god this is
almost scarily similar to what's
actually happening right so probably
smarter because people probably acted
much a lot smarter in that movie
i don't know no no no no no well then
but in that movie as well they would
just like instantly die
yeah yeah for some reason matt damon and
his kid i think were immune you were the
ones that were immune because of course
matt damon
i'm pretty sure if that happened matt
damon and tom cruise be [ __ ] immune
to him yeah
matt damon i think matt in the movie
matt damon was like i quarantined for
two weeks
never mind i'm immune now
[Laughter]
he leaned like that i stayed inside of a
room for two weeks and then the doctor
was like
guess you're immune now it's a pretty
good movie have you watched it
i've just seen clips of it yeah it's
pretty good it's pretty fun
watching it now being like yeah it's
[ __ ] weird it must be weird watching
it during the pandemic and seeing being
like
this is uh this is uncomfortably close
to what's happening now
it just makes you realize like how lucky
we got that it could have been
way worse like you could have just
immediately killed people yeah
because i i think you know we we've
obviously gone through a really harsh
period right now but i feel like
humanity really just got like we got the
best warnings yeah yeah this was this
was the best warning sign that
we could have gotten and i say this
obviously knowing that you know it's
it's a [ __ ] tragedy
how many people have died but the the
scary thing is that it could have been
so much [ __ ] worse yeah than it was
and this was this was kind of like the
worst case scenario for
how easily transmittable this virus
could have been but
in terms of like in terms of like its
actual effect it could have been a lot
worse
and i say this with the [ __ ] awful
results we've gotten
so far i mean it's just it's just scary
to think that you know if
this had happened you know 50 100 years
prior yeah like how much probably much
much much worse it could have been you
know
it's weird because i i've been thinking
about this a lot because it's uh
it's been like a full year now since
since i remember thinking
oh this is gonna this is gonna last a
few months this is
there's this quarantine thing right this
is a this is a little this is this is a
fun day everyone came together it's like
we'll bunk up for like two months and
then you know we'll be able to go
outside and enjoy the summer
i remember the joke was like oh anime
nerds haha i found
i was born for this yeah and then i kind
of you realize pretty soon that there's
a big difference between choosing to
stay home
and being forced to stay home there's i
don't know what it is but there's a big
[ __ ] difference
i saw a tweet that was like man are
people gonna judge people who have a
tough time readapting to
social situations right i was like what
what do you mean
what do you mean re-adapting like people
who have been uh
like in live in their house for too long
alone yeah they were like i hope we
don't get judged what
what they're suddenly gonna go outside
being like how do i interact with humans
yeah yeah
i thought it was a little odd
you don't you see [ __ ] like that on
twitter and it was just read something
like
it was like it they they made it out
like it was way more serious and like a
big issue than it was
and i'm like bro it's literally talking
to people what are you what are you
doing how is this not second nature to
you
i'm not i know people you know struggle
to socialize but acting as if like
your life has just been flipped upside
down and it's gonna take so much
readjusting like you'd
like to get over this i'm like bro it's
like it's like it's not like you trying
to learn
a language that you stopped learning
afterwards maybe maybe this is a shitty
take i don't know it could be a shitty
take i
i was just like what am i doing am i
dumb well you're obviously
not part of that right it's like hashtag
obviously i you know i know i'm quite
extroverted and i i obviously
can't sympathize 100 with all introvert
problems
but like you know i mean to me i was
like it kind of seemed like they were
trying to make it like
i don't know because sometimes twitter
does this where it's like guys guys
i have a problem guys i need to tell you
about my problem guys please come on
fellow i believe that i believe that's
called first world problems yeah maybe
yeah maybe
yeah or it's like the woe is me right
well i don't know like i
i i can kind of understand but at the
same time
how is it going to be different like how
are you gonna how is it that much
different from what you were like before
yeah it's like it's like
normal yeah i mean it's like no one's
gonna force you to go outside after the
pandemic if anything people are probably
gonna
just don't worry about it just go back
to being we'll just go back to the
situation people will choose to be
inside
taking a flight guard going on a plane
you know if you loved being inside
before the pandemic you're probably
still going to be inside after the
pandemic let's be real
no it's like the police aren't going to
come and be like all right you've been
in this room for too
long all right get the [ __ ] out get the
[ __ ] out you got it you gotta
do you think there are going to be any
big changes once this pandemic's over or
we're just going to be like
ah that was a funny thing that happened
last year right i mean like in terms of
japan
like you know because we're already such
a yeah do you think japan is never going
to stop wearing masks
now no like because before you know it
was still a socially accepted norm
for people to wear masks but not
everyone wore masks
and now i feel like now it's going to be
so deeply ingrained in the culture that
i feel like
90 to 80 percent of people are just
gonna be permanently wearing masks oh
yeah of course
i mean you know like people already wear
masks here like you know during
especially this time of year
like you know flu season yeah people
have hay fever because you know that
kind of stuff and then you know you have
like the influenza season in like
november where people are getting sick
all the [ __ ] time yeah everyone's
wearing a mask and it's like
is your face a little bit cold wear a
mask you know do you know what i'm
hoping
and i think it's going to happen and i'm
happy for it
people are going to take care of the
hygiene during conventions that's good
i don't know but you're asking them yeah
that's a tall order
i i i am hopeful that a global pandemic
will make nerds care more about the
hygiene during a big social gathering
am i am i being too hopeful for this am
i being grateful for this i feel you
know what i feel if anything it's going
to be like
listen we're all not going to get each
other sick now we've we've all gotten
the shot yeah
and and i've been and i've been forced
to use hand sanitizer and bathe and wash
my hands for
far too long i am going to go on a
bathing strike
i think i'd like to just see the like
the alcohol stay in front of like yeah
especially at conventions where you are
shaking hands with
so many [ __ ] people and you know you
know maybe wearing more masks in
convention that's
that's not exactly a bad thing because
con flu is just
an accepted part that is an accepted
part of every convention you go
you go to right well it's more like see
here's the one thing i've never
understood about conflict right like
right whenever you catch a cold
right it's usually from someone yeah
who's the [ __ ] who's going to a con
with a cold i mean there's loads of
people because i mean i get it right
like
if you if they booked it yeah yeah
you've you've already taken
them off work you've already paid money
you've booked your hotel yeah but
they'll get a cough
the least you can do is like try and
stay as hygienic as possible right
which is what you're talking about i
know
can we can we change this please like
that's that's what i'm saying
i'm i'm hoping that i go to the next
convention or maybe like not just the
next one because obviously the next
one's gonna be affected yeah but maybe
in like three years time we still got
the same etiquette of you know if
you know maybe wearing masks isn't such
a bad thing we're a master use hand
sanitizer
or people having hand sanitizers just
like easily readily available like if
i'm just like
oh [ __ ] does anyone have any hand
sanitizer and like three people around
me just be like yeah bro i got your back
i think that's the positive change maybe
you know maybe the smell can change but
that's that's just hopeful thing
that that is hopeful can we make those
ones that like [ __ ] wet your hand to
oblivion illegal you know the ones when
you get it and it's just like
a oil has been dropped on your head that
[ __ ] should be illegal
where it's like way too sticky but it's
like sticky it's
it's like feels like it's been hydrated
to like one thousand percent like it's
weird why do they keep buying this [ __ ]
stop making that that's the potent [ __ ]
dude
is it really though i i i like the
feeling of that one because
your hands feel clean because it's like
the man puts his hand in a tangle one
time and now he wants to like have his
[ __ ]
groove all over him
because like sometimes you get like you
go to a restaurant here and they're like
please please sanitize your hands and
they give you like this they spray like
the tiny spray on and you're
meant to like make this tiny spray last
like like cover your entire
absorbs into your palm before you
stretch it out i'm just like you you
know that picture where it's like the
door that's being held by the cheeto and
like the swat team
breaking down the door that's what it
feels like when they put like that
piddly little spray on and you're like
okay i can see this does nothing but
you're just doing it because it's like
regulation
yeah like i don't want my hand been feel
like i've just dunked it in like a vat
of oil
like that's what it feels like sometimes
i like the feeling of like
like it's one it covers your hands and
two you can feel it evaporate so you get
like a
little tingly cooling sensation i rather
than go overboard with the hand
sanitizer than on the board like i
i feel i feel like it's clean otherwise
it's it is [ __ ] it's like
i know there is my hands are the
cleanest it is sanitized that's that's
the point of hand sanitizing it [ __ ]
sanitizes
that point zero one percent of germs is
clinging on for dear life on my hands
right now like
i just prefer to use like soap i don't
know i like the food
all right spray a little bit on and i'm
going to go toilet and clean my hands
what takes so much more effort yeah but
i like that is the least
optimized thing yeah coming from a man
who optimizes everything in his list
restaurants aren't
inherently an unoptimized experience
there's so much waiting
image imagine the queue to the toilet
yeah if that if that was just
norm not everyone could be large brained
like myself you know
shut up just shut up all you have to do
is buy this gel
it sanitizes your hands more feel like
it strips your skin i don't know why
you're not even well that's just your
weak ass epidermis apparently it is it
is my weak ass epidemic
because sometimes i love it when i can
feel my bone
yeah because some people have just know
some people some people just have like
really sweaty hands and it feels like
you know that spray
that spray does nothing some people need
[ __ ] sweater your hands not my hands
my hands are like it's the one
that you handshake at a corn you know
it's it's the moist hand it's the
moisture
you felt the moist hand and for some
reason the moist hand always caught as
[ __ ]
it's like you feel the moistness
and you're literally a cold wet fish
that's what it feels like that's what it
feels like right it's like a dead fish
right it's like going to a supermarket
and like seeing one of those fish in the
fish it's actually just grabbing it
that's what it feels like
it is gross and you can never shake that
feeling off after it's like
off your hand yeah yeah yeah apologies
to anyone who has
cold wet hands but uh yeah
whoever's handshaking their fish at home
yeah sand shaking their fish arms
[Laughter]
yeah i mean i i would like to see that
from future cons but
i mean [ __ ] it's it's really it's just a
matter of
when is the future called it's just got
a postponed didn't you yeah yeah yeah
i i just have no interest in going to
digital conventions i couldn't think of
a more
boring thing it's it's it's just sad to
me
i get it they got to keep it they got to
do it but to me to me it doesn't
it doesn't make me feel happy that
they're doing digital conventions it
just makes me feel
sad yeah unless i'm staying in a scuffed
hotel room that's [ __ ] up from
every all everyone's [ __ ] like just not
the same yeah
it's it's kind of the same as like
virtual concerts yeah right
like like uh i thought the fortnite one
was pretty cool with like travis scott i
did a whole thing for it
that's like a different experience
that's a different experience but like
someone on zoom just dancing in front of
that webcam being like you know
did you see the one that post malone did
for pokemon no no
yeah postmo so like pokemon just
recently announced uh well
uh past the 25th anniversary this year
and
post the pokemon the official pokemon
youtube channel
did a virtual concert with post malone
and it is
weird it is weird as [ __ ]
did pokemon reach out to post malone or
was it
what it was like it was like literally
like think of think of like the travis
scott he's like the least
family-friendly kind of image you could
go for that
i expect from nintendo it was this clip
on twitter that went viral
where like one of the lyrics uh to like
post malone's song like obviously you
know like
a lot of his songs you know he swears
and writes so they said it but i guess
they forgot to censor this one line
where he was like
it was just the sex though the sex
though meanwhile there's lugia flying in
the distance
post malone rapping and it was like yeah
so like
they had like the the virtual model of
post malone
but again it's like in a pokemon way
not even it's like i don't know he was
kind of
halfway between a pokemon model and just
like
a regular 3d model okay and it was
really [ __ ] weird and especially
weird because like
when you think of pokemon and you think
of
modern pop stars yeah post malone is not
the first person you think of
no right and yet yeah it was really
weird just being like at the end of the
concert he's like
thank you pokemon fans
i love pokemons this happened how did i
not see that
i'm surprised you guys didn't see it
it's like kanye west going on the disney
channel or something
all these [ __ ]
you're such a [ __ ] heart i love
it thank you disney like sometimes you
just see
news nowadays and like you can't tell if
it's real news or just a meme anymore
like the real news is the meme nowadays
sometimes
like post malone and pokemon
i mean i like post malone but it was
just a very strange
like i don't know if i enjoyed it it's a
very odd combo it's a very odd combo
especially especially coming from
nintendo as well one of the most was
yeah yeah i mean it was it was good like
if you're a post malone or
a fan then it was like yeah cool you're
like pokemon yeah
i don't know about like pokemon fans but
i mean i saw it was like pretty
positively received
so i mean good on so it's kind of like a
pokemon amv
to post malone's music i don't even know
like it wasn't a long concert either it
was maybe about you know like
15 20 minutes maybe so he played you
know he maybe did like three or four so
wait where could you watch this was it
on twitter
it's on the pokemon it's on the official
pokemon youtube channel
like if you look up post malone pokemon
concert it'll come up
i just yeah i just don't want to be in
my room attending another this is just
like
that's just sad there's just something
about the energy of having a crowd there
that's just that that you need that
energy i mean it's something that you
can't because nothing's sadder than a
virtual mosh pit
yeah yeah oh god that sounds so
depressing yeah oh my god i'm playing
what's the virtual mosh pit it's just
twitch chat going insane right that's a
virtual mosh pins like it's
not quite the same i love twitch chat
and i i love interacting and i love
streaming but there's something about it
when it was supposed to be live
yeah like in person when it goes to
twitch it feels weird or yeah
it feels weird i don't really know why
and like conventions i just think are an
experience you inherently just cannot
experience
i mean you go to convention for the
people for the atmosphere otherwise
everyone would be [ __ ] going on their
discord service and talking about anime
being cringy exactly you go to be cringy
and personal yeah
meet other cringy people it's like the
whole reason why you go to like concerts
right it's like
it's it's of course to see whoever
you're seeing live but it's also to
[ __ ]
see it with people yeah there's
something different about seeing you
know
seeing a bland live as opposed with
other people
as opposed to seeing it you know
listening to the album or seeing music
videos
like that there's just there's just an
energy you can't capture if you're
watching it through a screen exactly
um and i mean that's that's why i get
why people have to do virtual events and
everything but i'm kind of i'm kind of
i just want to attend i [ __ ] miss
concerts i miss crowds
yeah and i never thought i would miss
crowds because like hey i hate crowds i
hate crowds so much but
like even like it's not just even being
there in a crowd but just
seeing an event and just hearing that
crowd scream
there's just something special there's
just something that brings that hype to
it yeah
i get that i get that like um the most
recent like
the most recent event i can think of is
uh league of legends worlds right
normally i'm like super super hyped for
worlds because as you would be for any
other sporting event
but there was just something about
seeing this gameplay
that just didn't have the crowd raw
behind it that just made it feel like
you were just watching a
tyler1 stream or something like that
yeah like you're watching an online
tournament yeah
yeah i remember the players they were
saying as well they were like yeah it's
not the same without a crowd yeah of
course when you get a win
you know when the crowd's that uh you
know like when someone makes a [ __ ]
amazing play
and you hear that roar there's just
something special about that that
even though i'm not there in person
because i've i've been to you know i've
been there in person and the energy
there is
[ __ ] incredible um but even just
capturing a bit of that energy and
putting it like just hearing that crowd
scream
it's it's it's something that can't be
replicated and
like i know um and i i think it was
china
that tried adding like that that they
tried the cans laughter effect where
they they they added
fake crowds effects yeah yeah yeah to
the league of legends yeah yeah i think
so i heard
about this this stuff like someone's
probably gonna fact check and call me
out on this but i think i heard that and
that just sounds i wouldn't be surprised
that just sounds even worse
yeah if they did that just like the
friends [ __ ] like soundtrack started
playing like the science old bass just
comes in
yeah because like i remember like uh you
know because february just passed and
like i love watching like the sumo
yeah and the sumo season is like during
the winter yeah so just finished but
like of course because it's a pandemic
you can't have people in this tiny you
know stadium
watching the summer so like yeah it was
really sad to see this like
massive sumo stadium only having maybe
like four people in it yeah
and it's just like and you know
obviously after every win right usually
the crowd you know like claps or like
cheers or something
but instead it's like someone does this
like epic win yeah and like
three people are clapping it just sounds
like a cow [ __ ] it just feels like
there's zero stakes
yeah you can't if you can't hear
anything it's not hype at all yeah
that's really interesting cause the sumo
they were like all wearing mash before
they got on stage yeah they take it off
yeah
it's just funny seeing them like all
right we have these precautions they
take their masks off they step up and
immediately just
[ __ ] put their faces together i'm
like yeah i don't know i don't know
about this
there's not so much point i don't know
how socially distant sumoing is but i
mean
it is funny how crowds can play into
sporting event hype because i
so i've been recommended a lot of like
since we did the chess tournament i've
been
like been recommended way more chess
clips and been watching like share
streamers like
hikaru and everything like that and
there's just
like there's just something about the
image i had about chess before that was
boring
and i feel a big part of that was just
how bored everyone looks in any big
chess crowd right it's it's like it's
like people playing a chess tournament
during a coughing
coughing event yeah and and what i've
what i've realized
i like one thing i've realized about how
we could like how the the image could be
easily changed was i was recommending
this other events
like clips of this other event where
it's just a bunch of grand masters
um who went who are just like chewing
[ __ ]
uh shooting [ __ ] and having fun and they
were like having team tournaments and
just like
and like trash talking each other and
i'm just like dude this seems like a
legit fun event and this
this could have easily changed the image
of chess
which i think it's it's great now that
the image of chess is being like slowly
changed
you know i know not everyone will agree
with you going down
i mean that's that's my opinion as a
filthy casual chess player
gm tweeted out being like man it's such
a shame that chess is going in this
direction
yeah and then everyone's just like in
like a not serious direction yeah
yeah because you know chess has a lot of
history behind it and there's a lot of
people who are like it's it's
you know it's it's big brain it's
intelligent and it's being watered down
for these common folk you know
yes i mean you you are like an ex you
know you you've played chess
yeah i mean for your country how do you
feel about it i mean you can it doesn't
really seem like you had that like
purest view on it yeah
no because like i hated it because like
when i was doing it it was a bunch of
you know 60 year old white men who would
just be in charge of everything
and they talked about it like you were
like the [ __ ] night's god
yeah yeah culture like yeah because you
know it's taken very seriously in the uk
and the history behind it is like very
long and you know what not but
you know i don't give a [ __ ] i mean you
know if if the sports
you know wants to have more funding and
be more popular i think it's good thing
people get into chess i mean yeah it's a
good game
i think that it's you know one of the
probably the better better games your
kid can get into
yeah um i mean it's gonna evolve
together with the times right and pure
is always
behind you know i mean you know
unfortunately chess is
probably on its own a bit boring yeah
let's be honest right like i play it
i you know say that but i think you know
adding these tournaments that
don't really take away anything from the
pro scene you know if it gets you know
if you look at chess viewership on
twitch you know outside of like pog
champs and stuff like that
the big chess streamers viewership has
grown a lot i mean
how many street how many viewers does
hikaru get now it's [ __ ]
25k yeah and it's it's [ __ ] great
because before you literally could not
make money
play like players there's so many big
chat streamers now yeah and it's really
epic
you know epic one it's really
interesting that's coming up
it's pretty epic seeing uh that like you
know there's room for
like many chess streamers to make a
living off this and stream it and you
know
i mean it makes sense right like i mean
it it's really taught me how important
images
yeah in regards to like a sport and
stuff like that because yes you know
there's there's
there's you know you got to respect the
legacy and history and stuff like that
but you get to a point where
it's modernized yeah it needs to
modernize they need to catch up with the
times and i've
it's great because i've gotten way more
into chess simply because
it just it just looks funner yeah you
know it looks way more fun
and i mean there's like like stuff like
you know
everyone thinks that sports like rules
don't change yeah like rules are like
sacred but like stuff like basketball
i'm pretty sure the nba changes the rule
have changed the rules a few times based
on what makes a
more fun viewing experience yeah yeah so
it begs to question is like what's more
important the sport or
the audience yeah and so i think chess
is out there for crossroads where
there's obviously people who have been
training their whole life to be
you know pros and whatnot yeah and
obviously it sucks that maybe your sport
is a little less serious
but on the other hand you have way more
opportunities way more money
you know way more chance to have a
platform and do whatever you want and if
you want to
be on the sidelines being salty about it
you're probably going to be the one left
behind yeah
it's it's a balance at the end of the
day right yeah you can't go too far in
either direction
yeah i feel that like i remember when
hikari got signed up for tsm
i was just like holy [ __ ] that's pretty
cool this this is a pogba
that is a part right
like like just just like imagine imagine
if we had a chess tournament where
people showed up in like esports gowns
you know in
[ __ ] esports shirts and stuff like
that that would be pretty hype in my
opinion but obviously i'm a filthy
casual
don't play i don't play chess out of
anything but just casually so
that's just my opinion i totally forgot
i played in chatham like last week
i totally forgot i did that oh yeah yeah
oh yeah
yeah it was fine i mean i had like one
hour sleep so it's pretty brutal and i
had to film
like i had to go somewhere i mean you
say that but you're like knowing your
schedule i kind of like
i was like kind of you were you're
addicted to apex back then
yeah yeah yeah you kind of did it to
yourself yeah you kind of did it you
know i did i just you know you just say
yes to something and you're like you
don't really think about like how it
will like
actually fit into your schedule it just
sounds cool until it happens
yeah so i got invited to twitch rivals
which was like they wanted to do like a
chess tournament where
you get paired with like a gm or
something and they tell you which piece
to move
and you have to choose which of that
piece if they say pawn
you choose which of the eight pawns to
move right and so it's pretty fun i mean
yeah
i haven't played chess in a like since
our tournament yeah so i was pretty
rusty and obviously
not having much sleep and so yeah but it
was good fun i like doing it it's fun i
like playing chess but it's really
annoying how like there's some comments
as well that like bro
conor wasn't kind of didn't play like
when he was a kid that's a lie he's so
[ __ ] now and i'm like
bro if you didn't play for like seven
years and you played now i bet you
probably wouldn't ever heard about you
ever heard of a gap
yeah yeah and also i think i'm probably
like the same
level or probably better as a child than
i am now yeah
yeah which could be weird to say i mean
like yeah i mean i mean
it's the same logic it's like oh you
learned the quadratic equation during
school and you can't do it now you
didn't learn it
yeah it's also like people think like
you know how good do you think that like
12 11 year olds are at this game like
yeah
i mean i yeah there are some exceptions
of amazing
characters there's only so many magnus
castles right yeah yeah yeah yeah
and i was like bro i was like the worst
on my team yeah i just sneaked in
like i remember when i was talking about
you know my uh
my masters and i was like explain to you
i couldn't remember what
equation i was talking about it was
second order differential equations i
remember that now and
connor says is it integer you're
thinking of and i guess i was like
yeah i guess there was i think i should
know too as well i also have an
engineering yeah there was so many
comments being like god's word
god didn't pass his masters can't even
remember that jesus christ
if you don't use something surprisingly
you forget it yeah you'll
have to understand that a lot of times
during this podcast a lot of us are just
brain dead
we're just we're just chatting it's just
like again you know it's the whole vibe
of the show
we just talk we don't really plan
anything none of the topics ever planned
beforehand we just
we just kind of shoot the [ __ ] you know
we didn't plan to go in the [ __ ]
masters talk of engineering
like i'm sure if i applied for an
engineering job i'm more qualified than
someone who is like hasn't got the
degree but might be studying that thing
yeah who probably knows more than me at
this current time but because i haven't
done anything
yeah like three years like [ __ ] i don't
know i mean you forget
you forget i forgot everything i did i
finally understand that he knew it at
the time yeah
that's the thing i i feel like now i
finally understand how like
my parents felt when i was like going to
them and being like can you help me with
this math equation it's like you you
finished school right you've done this
before
and my parents are like uh i i don't
know how to do this i'm like what do you
mean you don't know how to do it
you did this in school i think i can't
even remember like having passed my
masters in engineering i probably can't
remember how to do basic trigonometry
now
if someone came if like some
ten-year-old came up to me and was like
can you help me solve this long division
equation i'd be like [ __ ] so far
i don't know how to [ __ ] to do this to
like research real quick but i'm sure
i can get the answer let me google it
real quick like i totally get that now
yeah because i remember as a kid you're
just like
how can you not know this you're an
adult you know everything you learned
this before
you know how you see this [ __ ] like
facebook quizzes that pop up that are
like
you know it'll be like different tanks
of water it'll be like which one will
fill up first
yeah and that was like literally like
part of my fluids exam we had stuff like
that and i'm like back in the day i'm
sure i can answer that
right now i got no [ __ ] idea because
i don't remember what the [ __ ] it was
all about
all right well i guess we have nothing
else to talk about today boys so
hand it off to you the host gone we just
we just
put me away i can't remember what we
ended up
i've talked enough i'm satisfied hello
patrons thank you for being a patron
here are all your names
you guys are beautiful amazing look at
all your beautiful faces
hey if you'd like to support us go over
to patreon.com also follow us on twitter
the subreddit and listen to us on
spotify if you hate our face i i just
feel like joey does it so much better
than either of us because he's just like
ingrained that into up
into his head i literally just like
mentally i just like press a button at
this order place
i could i just choose not to yeah i mean
joey does it for me every time and i'm
just like
just like just let joey don't do it hey
man don't fix something that isn't
broken
yes do everything that joey says and uh
did you mention that we have a twitch
channel as well oh yeah we haven't
mentioned that we have a third channel
now
oh yeah dewey trash tastes after dark it
used to be unofficial
and now it's official yeah i know that
confused a lot of people it's it's very
it's very confusing because there are
some channels out there that
aren't official and there are some
channels out there that are official i
mean
we're like yeah so let's let's set the
record straight we have three channels
we have this one that you're currently
on we have trash taste highlights and we
have trash taste after dark anything
else
is unofficial yes where we will be
uploading our twitch streams yes that's
what you're doing so basically after
dark is literally just a
vod of our twitch twitch streams yeah
and you know there might be other like
you know [ __ ] content yeah as well
but for the time being all of the twitch
fords oh yeah by the way follow us on
twitch as well uh yeah
podcast uh we'll be doing like
semi-regular streams i don't [ __ ]
know
i don't know we have some stream ideas
no promises
but uh it's there yeah it's follow us
just follow us there
anyway that's it has been very tired
today no i mean i was good the first now
and then i'm just like bro it hit me
yeah this is this is how i've seen you
for the past week because connor's been
addicted to apex
for like the past month and every time i
see him he doesn't distill himself
every time i see him he just comes in
and be like guys i was streaming till
like 4 00 am
i didn't stream yesterday i'm just tired
[Music]
most of the time he doesn't even stream
he just plays yeah i'm just like
anyway that's it from us so we'll see
you guys next time
[Music]
you